HAVE A GREAT WEEKEND,
"THE STORY"
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT"."
JOE BIDEN HASN’T WAITED TOO
DEEPLY INTO QUESTIONS OF PUBLIC
POLICY, WHATEVER ELSE BIDEN MAY
BE DOING, LOOKING AT FUNNY CAT
VIDEOS ON THE INTERNET,
SHUFFLING THROUGH HIS MAILBOX
EVERY AFTERNOON, IT’S FAIR TO
SAY HE IS NOT RUNNING A CAMPAIGN
ABOUT IDEAS.
BUT BIDEN HAS MADE AT LEAST ONE
CAMPAIGN PROMISE SO FAR, HE HAS
PLEDGED IF ELECTED HE WILL FORCE
YOU TO WEAR A MASK WHEN YOU GO
OUTSIDE.
HE DIDN’T SPECIFY WHICH
EPIDEMIOLOGICAL STUDIES WOULD
JUSTIFY A LAW LIKE THAT, THAT’S
PROBABLY BECAUSE THERE AREN’T
ANY.
NOT A SINGLE ONE -- BUT
WHATEVER.
HE’S NEVER BEEN MUCH OF A
SCIENCE GUY, HE’S A LIFELONG
POLITICIAN.
HIS SPECIALTY IS POWER AND
COERCION SO HE DOES WHAT HE
KNOWS.
WEARING A MASK WHEN YOU RIDE
YOUR BIKE ALONE COULD POSSIBLY
SAVE ANYONE’S LIFE, HE INSTEAD
DEMAND TO FORGET ABOUT YOUR
SO-CALLED RIGHTS AS AN AMERICAN
AND OBEY HIS ORDERS, NO
QUESTIONS ALLOWED -- OTHERWISE
YOU’RE UNPATRIOTIC.
IF IT SOUNDS FAMILIAR, THAT’S
BECAUSE WE SING A LOT OF THIS
LATELY.
TERRIFIED, UNHAPPY POPULATIONS
WANT CHANGE AND THAT’S WELCOME
NEWS TO THE PARTY TRYING TO TAKE
POWER, THAT’S WHY THEY ARE DOING
IT.
WHAT’S THE COST TO THE REST OF
US, TO AMERICA?
IT’S PROFOUND.
THANKS TO RESTRICTIONS ROOTED IN
POLITICS RATHER THAN SCIENCE,
CHILDREN CAN’T GO TO SCHOOL,
PARENTS CAN’T GO TO WORK, PEOPLE
CAN’T GET MARRIED OR ATTEND
FUNERALS.
HUMAN CONTACT HAS BEEN
DRASTICALLY CURTAILED, THESE ARE
NOT SMALL THINGS.
THEY ARE ESSENTIAL HUMAN NEEDS.
WITHOUT THEM, WE CAN’T LIVE.
IN MAY, WE TALKED TO A FATHER
WHOSE TEENAGE SON KILLED HIMSELF
WE HE BELIEVED BECAUSE OF
ISOLATION.
HERE’S PART OF THE CONVERSATION.
>> MY YOUNG 12-YEAR-OLD BOY
ABOUT THREE DAYS BEFORE HIS 13TH
BIRTHDAY TOOK HIS LIFE.
HE WAS A NORMAL KID, HE WASN’T
DEPRESSED, HE DIDN’T DIE OF THE
COVID VIRUS BUT HE CERTAINLY
DIED BECAUSE OF THE COVID VIRUS.
ISOLATION CREATED WHAT I BELIEVE
AND WHAT I WORRY AND I’M WARNING
EVERY PARENT IN AMERICA TONIGHT,
UNEMOTIONAL TSUNAMI THAT IS
SWEEPING THIS NATION AND I’M
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT IT.
>> Tucker: HE HAD REASON TO BE
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT IT, THAT
WAS THREE MONTHS AGO -- THE
COUNTRY HAS BECOME SADDER AND
MORE ISOLATED SENSE.
THE LOCKDOWN HAS GIVEN AMERICANS
TO THE EDGE AND THAT’S NOT
SPECULATION.
ACCORDING TO NEW DATA FROM THE
CDC, FULLY A QUARTER OF ALL
YOUNG PEOPLE IN THIS COUNTRY
BETWEEN 18 AND 24 RECENTLY HAVE
CONSIDERED SUICIDE, SERIOUSLY
THOUGHT ABOUT KILLING
THEMSELVES -- THAT IS A MASSIVE
AND A TERRIFYING OVER PREVIOUS
SURVEYS.
IT’S A TRAGEDY.
ANXIETY AND DEPRESSION ARE AT
RECORD HIGHS, MANY AMERICANS ARE
FALLING INTO A SPIRAL FROM WHICH
THEY WILL NOT ESCAPE.
>> BECAUSE OF CORONAVIRUS, MANY
PEOPLE ARE NOW UNEMPLOYED OR
ISOLATED AT HOME.
AS A RESULT, THE DRUG EPIDEMIC
HAS INTENSIFIED.
>> YOU DO WHATEVER IT IS YOU DO
AND THE WORLD GOES AWAY FOR A
WHILE.
>> JOE RUNS A FRESH START
MINISTRIES IN ORLANDO AND SAYS
THEY ARE SEEING MORE RELAPSES
AND STORIES OF DRUG ABUSE AS A
RESULT.
NATIONWIDE, IT’S THE SAME STORY.
THE NATIONAL INSTITUTE ON DRUG
ABUSE ESTIMATES THAT SINCE THE
OUTBREAK, OVERDOSES ARE UP
BETWEEN 30 AND 40%.
>> Tucker: PEOPLE ARE
DEPRESSED, YOU SEE IT ALL AROUND
YOU, THEY ARE DEPRESSED BECAUSE
THEY ARE CUT OFF FROM ONE
ANOTHER, DEPRESSED BECAUSE THEIR
LIVES ARE MOVING BACKWARDS.
12% OF THE AMERICAN HOUSEHOLDS
IN THE RICHEST COUNTRY IN THE
WORLD ARE NOW ROUTINELY SHORT ON
FOOD.
A 20% OF ALL RENTERS IN AMERICA
ARE BEHIND ON PAYMENTS.
THESE DATA WERE COLLECTED BEFORE
FEDERAL UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS
EXPIRED.
PEOPLE ARE ABANDONING THEIR
PETS, PRESCRIPTIONS ARE GOING
UNFILLED, WE CAN GO ON.
BIG PARTS OF THE COUNTRY ARE
BECOMING POOR BUT YOU DON’T HEAR
ABOUT IT MUCH BECAUSE TO THE
MEDIA AND OUR LEADERS IN
WASHINGTON, IT’S NOT A BIG DEAL.
THEY CAN’T IMAGINE WORRYING
ABOUT MONEY.
IN WASHINGTON, THEY LIVE IN A
CITY WITH GUARANTEED FULL
EMPLOYMENT ALWAYS AND FOREVER
THANKS TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT, IT AFFECTS THEIR
ATTITUDES.
HERE IS TONY FAUCI, THE MOST
POLITICAL MAN IN THE MOST
POLITICAL CITY IN AMERICA
TELLING YOU THAT GOING BROKE
ISN’T REALLY A BIG DEAL.
>> I KNOW IT’S DIFFICULT, WE ARE
HAVING A LOT OF SUFFERING, A LOT
OF DEATH, IF IT’S
INCONVENIENT -- BUT WE JUST HAVE
TO DO IT.
>> Tucker: IT’S INCONVENIENT?
REMEMBER WHEN YOU RESPECTED THAT
GUY?
REMEMBER WHAT HE SEEMED LIKE A
LEGITIMATE PUBLIC HEALTH EXPERT?
WE DO, HE WAS ON THIS SHOW, WE
TREATED HIM LIKE A PHYSICIAN.
NOW IT’S CLEAR FAUCI IS ANOTHER
OILY POLITICIAN ON AN EGO TRIP.
IN CASE YOU HAVEN’T BEEN TO A
SUPERMARKET RECENTLY, HE’S
FEATURED ON THE COVER OF IN
STYLE MAGAZINE PHOTOGRAPHED BY
THE POOL -- MEN OF SCIENCE, WHAT
A BUFFOON.
HE ISN’T SUFFERING DURING THE
LOCKDOWNS, HE’S LOVING IT.
HE’S ENJOYING THE HELL OUT OF
HIMSELF.
SO IS CNN.
JEFF ZUCKER UNDERSTANDS THE
LOCKDOWNS ARE THE ONLY WAY HIS
PERSONAL FRIEND KAMALA HARRIS IS
GOING TO RUN THE COUNTRY, HIS
ANCHORS DUTIFULLY BERET TO THE
PUBLIC NOT OBEYING EVEN AS THEY
IGNORE THE RULES THEY DEMAND YOU
FOLLOW.
WATCH THE BODY BUILDERS ROI TO
RANTS ON THE SUBJECT.
>> WHILE MOST AMERICANS ARE
STAYING INSIDE AND SHOULD BE,
THEY AREN’T HAPPY ABOUT BEING
TOLD TO STAY HOME.
STAYING HOME STAYS SAVES LIVES.
>> THE REST OF US SHOULD BE
STAYING AT HOME FOR OUR MOTHERS
AND THE PEOPLE WE LOVE AND
KEEPING FARTHER APART WILL
ULTIMATELY BRING US CLOSER
TOGETHER.
OUR COLLECTIVE CONSCIENTIOUS
ACTIONS -- STAY HOME.
>> Tucker: STAY HOME!
THAT’S THE ORDER EXCEPT WHEN YOU
ARE PLEDGING ALLEGIANCE TO THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
IN THAT CASE, FEEL FREE TO FILL
UP THE STREETS, THAT’S HEALTHY.
IN NEW YORK CITY, LOCAL
POLITICIANS GATHERED IN FRONT OF
TRUMP TOWER TO PLAY PAINT BLACK
MATTER -- EVEN BILL de BLASIO
SHOWED UP HIGH AS A KITE AS
USUAL AND DID HIS BEST TO MAKE A
STRAIGHT LINE.
JEFF ZUCKER DIDN’T COMPLAIN, THE
MEDIA LOVED IT.
KEEP IN MIND, NOT ALL PUBLIC
GATHERINGS ARE EQUALLY SAFE,
SOME ARE INCREDIBLY DANGEROUS.
IT’S HARD TO KNOW THE DIFFERENCE
UNLESS YOU ARE POLITICALLY
ATTUNED.
IN NEW YORK, THE CITY ANNOUNCED
IT WILL NOT COMMEMORATE 9/11 AS
IT ALWAYS DOES THIS YEAR, THE
TRADITIONAL TWIN BEAMS OF LIGHT
OVER MANHATTAN WILL BE DARK NEXT
MONTH.
WHY?
BECAUSE OFFICIALS SAY THEY CAN’T
RISK THE SAFETY OF THE CRUISE
THEY WOULD NEED TO SET UP THE
MEMORIAL.
TURNING ON TWO LIGHTS IS JUST
TOO DANGEROUS RIGHT NOW, THERE’S
A PANDEMIC OUT THERE.
DO YOU TAKE THEM AT THEIR WORD?
DO YOU THINK THAT’S A REAL
PROBLEM?
YOU KNOW WHAT’S GOING ON.
ANYTHING THAT BRINGS PEOPLE
TOGETHER THAT UNITES US AS A
NATION, THAT GIVES PEOPLE PRIDE
IN THEIR COUNTRY MUST BE
STOPPED.
ANYTHING THAT CAUSES DIVISION,
FEAR, PANIC, ANXIETY, HATRED
MUST BE AMPLIFIED, NO MATTER HOW
MANY KIDS KILL THEMSELVES AS A
RESULT.
THERE’S AN ELECTION COMING UP.
HERE’S DR. BIDEN EXPLAINING THE
RULES.
>> IF OUR PRESIDENT TODAY -- I
WOULD ROLL BACK RE-OPENINGS IN A
NUMBER OF PLACES.
WHEREVER THERE IS A SIGNIFICANT
PERCENTAGE OF PEOPLE WITH COVID
IT SHOULD BE REQUIRED TO KEEP
SOCIAL DISTANCING AND MASKS,
BARS SHOULD NOT BE OPEN, THERE
SHOULD NOT BE CONGREGATIONS OF
MORE THAN TEN PEOPLE.
>> Tucker: AFTER CONSULTING
WITH HIS ADVISORS, ALL THE
POLITICAL ADVISORS, BIDEN HAS
LOCATED THE CORE OF THE PROBLEM.
IT TURNS OUT AMERICA ISN’T SHUT
DOWN ENOUGH.
PEOPLE MIGHT BE TEMPTED TO GO TO
CHURCH OR HAVE DINNER WITH THEIR
FRIENDS OR WORK FOR A LIVING.
KIDS COULD WIND UP IN SCHOOL AND
LEARN THINGS THAT HAVEN’T BEEN
PRESCREENED BY GOOGLE.
SOMEWHERE A YOUNG COUPLE MIGHT
DECIDE TO TAKE A WALK THROUGH
THE WOODS WITHOUT MASKS TO ENJOY
NATURE AND FRESH AIR AND IF
THINGS LIKE THAT CONTINUE,